true yes but what do you do when bad
things happen move ahead
gotta move ahead yeah get a move ahead
and try to make a difference in the
world
retired astronaut Mark Kelly announced
this week he's running to represent
Arizona in the Senate if he's successful
in winning the seat once held by John
McCain Kelly would join a small club of
congressmen who have traveled in space
John Glenn blazed the trail both in
space and on Capitol Hill he was the
first American to orbit the earth back
in 1962 and then became the first
astronaut elected to Congress in 1974
Glenn spent 25 years as a senator from
Ohio and in his last term returned to
space in 1998 at the age of 77 before he
was elected to represent New Mexico in
the Senate Jack Schmitt was the last
human to walk on the moon while on the
Apollo 17 mission Schmitt snapped a
picture of Earth known as the Blue
Marble perhaps the most famous photo of
our planet and Jack Swigert is
responsible for one of the most famous
lines in NASA history 12 years after he
and the crew of the Apollo 13 safely
returned to Earth after their ill-fated
lunar mission Swigert was elected to
represent Colorado's sixth House
District but he died before he was sworn
in the path of mission 51 jake garn
became the first sitting member of
congress to visit space the Utah senator
was head of the subcommittee overseeing
NASA when he flew aboard space shuttle
Discovery in 1985 I remember the first
thing from the Capcom was welcome to
space rookies former Florida Senator
Bill Nelson traveled to space in 1986
while he was a member of the House of
Representatives Nelson says the
experience of spaceflight and looking
back at our planet changed his
perspective I've seen that the daily
little rigors
the daily little spats they seemed a
little less important if Mark Kelly wins
the Democratic nomination for Arizona's
Senate seat he will likely face another
high flyer in the general election
senator martha mcsalley who currently
holds the seat is the first female
fighter pilot to fly a combat mission in
air force history in the first 48 hours
after Kelly announced he raised a
million dollars and obviously if he
needs any advice he just looks to his
wife former representative Gabby hurt
there and she can offer plenty that
could be a real Star Wars race there
that